millions expressed on this program are
those of the guests appearing on the
program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group we have hope now
a vaccine is coming within weeks
tonight on politics now looking for a
light at the end of the tunnel
the new timeline for a covet 19 vaccine
and who gets it first
our election is now official the change
of course from clark county in a race
decided by just 10 votes
plus i'm alexandra limon in washington
where lawmakers continue to be stalled
over a new coronavirus relief package
and one senator warns the worst of the
pandemic
could still be ahead of us
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
while nevada faces more covet 19 cases
there is hope on the horizon
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler governor
steve sisselak says he hopes to have the
first round of vaccination doses
available
here by the middle of december the state
will give frontline health care workers
the first possible doses and then
nursing home workers
vaccines are scheduled to be available
to the public by the spring or
summer of twenty twenty one governor
sysolak and his team say medicine for
moderna and pfizer are about 95 percent
effective
we have hope now a vaccine is coming
within weeks
we will begin distributing and giving
people needle sticks
i mean that's a positive thing this has
been done in record time
and it's our hope that we can get as
much of this as we can out in the
general public
we'll build more and more immunity and
we can start to get back to our regular
lives
the vaccine will be administered in two
doses and the first available again
this month the time in between doses
will be
either 21 or 28 days however coronavirus
has obviously
devastated nevada's economy new details
from the legislative economic forum show
just how much damage has been done since
june the state's total gaming revenue is
down 27.2 percent
that's 1.4 billion dollars in this graph
analysts project a gradual recovery over
the next few years
nevada's gaming control board projects
8.7 billion dollars in revenue for the
next fiscal year
that's a drop of 11.2 percent locals
tend to drive the slot machine numbers
it's table games like blackjack that are
more dependent on international visitors
many resorts on the strip have closed
hotel operations during the slow midweek
days
we're having a slow period on top of the
fact we don't have any events that
pump up the business during that time
period nfr is gone
um for this year uh new year's i can't
imagine our new year's is going to be
anywhere near what we've experienced in
the past
and then uh january the large the large
conventions the the ces
that's not happening so i think it's
going to be a challenging
couple months the live entertainment tax
took the biggest hit here in nevada more
than 99
there were no shows analysts say the
vaccine announcement though is
good news for their projections of the
economy moving forward
another thing that would help in nevada
another coronavirus relief bill
however coronavirus cases are surging
nationwide
as alexander limon reports some
lawmakers say the relief
needs to come now
we're dealing with the corona virus
pandemic but they're also dealing with a
hunger pandemic and they have never seen
anything like this
oregon senator ron wyden says americans
will likely see both the health and
economic
impacts of the pandemic get worse over
the coming months
a tsunami of evictions people
losing their homes that's why he and top
democrats
introduced the american worker holiday
relief act which allows americans to
qualify for 26 additional weeks of
unemployment benefits and extends the
600
a week federal boost through october of
2021.
it also ensures freelance and gig
economy workers qualify for extended
benefits
for months lawmakers have failed to
reach an agreement on a new coveted
relief package
in part because they can't agree on
whether to extend the extra 600
a week in unemployment benefits larry
kudlow director of the national economic
council says the white house isn't
against extending unemployment benefits
but he suggests paying for it with the
hundreds of billions of dollars that are
left over from previous relief packages
repurpose it back to the ppps the
unemployment assistance
school kobit related k-12 assistance
there's some airlines democrats say the
cost of the long-term economic relief
that's needed
will surpasses the amount of money
that's left over
in washington alexandra limon
joining us now our washington dc bureau
reporter alexander limon to talk about
covid 19 relief it does appear alex
there is some momentum on capitol hill
for a
compromise on some sort of a package
what are the details and
is it likely to pass that's right and
this bill comes from a group of
lawmakers that call themselves the
problem solvers caucus they are a group
of democrats and republicans that strive
to come up with
bipartisan pieces of legislation and in
this case they've come up with a 900
billion dollar
coveted relief bill that they say is a
really good compromise between democrats
and republicans
some of the things that it offers is
more help for small businesses via the
paycheck protection program
also some money for state and local
governments for airlines
and also money for covid testing
and for a vaccine distribution program
what it does not include is another
round of those
direct stimulus check payments to
americans
it does however include more money for
extended
unemployment insurance and this is where
the compromise part comes in
it includes 300 additional unemployment
insurance a week for 18 weeks you may
remember democrats were really set on
that 600
a week number and they wanted it for at
least 26 more weeks so that's where
they're compromising and it also
includes protections uh for for
businesses from kobet related lawsuits
again this is something democrats that
were
set against that they're saying we are
willing to consider
this in order to get something done on
covet relief
let's say lawmakers do reach an
agreement on capitol hill
how quickly could it actually get passed
and made into reality
well it really depends on whether they
can reach an agreement you know senator
mitch mcconnell has said he will not
call a bill to the floor unless he
thinks that
thinks that president trump would sign
it but that's really interesting because
it's different messaging than what we're
hearing from white house officials like
larry kudlow and steven mnuchin for
example they've actually seemed
more supportive of this compromise bill
and said that the president would sign
it
if mitch mcconnell supported it so if
they can reach some sort of a compromise
bill it's very likely that they would
attach it to the budget bill that
they're trying to work on
they have to get that passed by december
11 in order to try to avoid a government
shutdown
so it's very likely that a covet bill
could be attached to that in order to
get it passed you know within the next
few days
that is alexander limon from washington
with her dog
for the i-team's david charns asked
nevada democratic senator catherine
cortez-masto about the potential for a
relief bill
and her new leadership position as the
vice chair of outreach
is this an issue in terms of senate
leadership
that's holding this whole thing up or is
this something else i mean you're
you're in you're in there on the on the
floor in the chamber so what are your
what are you seeing so how the rules
work in the senate who's ever in control
whoever the majority leader of the
senate controls what goes on the floor
of the senate for votes
whether whatever legislation whether
there can be amendments whether there
can be debates
right now mitch mcconnell is control of
the senate so he has controlled what
goes on to the floor and he has refused
to bring forward
the house bills that have already passed
to bring additional relief
into um our communities and so
many of us not just democratic senators
but some of my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle have been demanding
that we have support bipartisan support
negotiations
around another package for relief
because it is so
needed in our communities it should have
been done months ago listen i was just
home
last week i went to a mobile food site
that three square has put together there
were over 350
cars in line and they started lining up
at 3 a.m
there was so much food insecurity
because our economy in nevada has been
devastated by this pandemic so
more relief yes is needed and so that's
why i support this bipartisan proposal
it gets additional relief into our
communities
in the next four months that's necessary
right now
congratulations on your uh new
leadership position
um with the democratic party moving into
the next
congress do you plan to do anything or
or does that give us or does that give
you know nevada a little bit of a leg up
in any way in terms of what comes across
uh at the senate yes it does and that's
why i was honored to be in leadership
because my focus is
nevada first and foremost always and now
in a leadership position
i could use my voice from nevada to
advocate for nevadans
and so yes that's number one number two
um
with the transition that we have with
the new administration
i'm already engaging in conversations
with the transition team
and and moving into how we create a
long-term infrastructure
to continue to communicate with the next
administration for needs that we have in
nevada
and so this is something that i intend
to capitalize on not only the leadership
position
but my opportunity to really build a
relationship with the new administration
to focus on the needs of nevadans
we have that entire interview available
for you over at 8newsnow.com just look
for the politics now tab
coming up here on politics now ccsd
reverses course
it's a a policy that
you can barely read four sentences
without hitting something that it gets
wrong
the school district's policy on
regulating free speech of employees and
the strong reaction against it
welcome back to politics now
the closest race in our 2020 election is
now official
however there is going to be a recount
for now democrat ross miller will
fill the clark county commission seat c
and that is
because he beat republican staff ross
anthony by 10 votes
this week election officials in clark
county switched course and certified the
vote
now at first they asked for a re-vote
because of the large number of
discrepancies
it was larger than the margin between
the two candidates of just 10 votes
discrepancies are things like when a
person signs in to vote but fails to
actually cast one
a judge ruled this week a revote
wouldn't necessarily change the results
so miller was certified as the winner
over 150 000 people voted in this
contest
it's very out of the ordinary for a a
race with that many votes to be decided
by
10. that margin of victory is very
difficult to reconcile no matter what
the race is with 215 precincts in it
on thursday anthony stavros-anthony said
he would ask for
a recount the election staff will start
working on that on monday
and it should be finished finished by
next friday also clark county registrar
joe gloria who you just heard from
he says his office has received hundreds
of calls from people who received false
information
about their vote not being counted
now an update on the litigation filed by
republicans in the trump campaign here
in nevada
nevada republicans have now dropped
their federal lawsuit which claimed
widespread voter fraud
now you might remember that news
conference two days after the election
when republicans announced this law
this lawsuit it alleged roughly ten
thousand people cast ballots
even though they don't live in nevada
anymore they also claimed dead voters
had ballots cast in their names
a separate state lawsuit filed by the
trump campaign trying to stop the
electors from casting their votes for
joe biden
well that is still waiting for a ruling
those six democratic electors are
scheduled to cast their votes for
the president-elect joe biden on
december 14th
just before thanksgiving the clark
county school district posted a
controversial proposal
about redefining employee-free speech
but as soon as it went up on the
district district's website
well it was removed basically right
after the holiday kristen drummond shows
us the concerns from ccsd
staff and the legality of the measure we
all should be standing up
uncertainty and unease this is like the
worst
possible time for them to roll out
something like this
ccsd staff and parents questioned the
intention of a policy proposal removed
suddenly monday evening from the
district website
a two-page document titled employee
freedom of speech
these are screen shots of the regulation
that seems to impose restrictions on
when employees can talk freely about
public concerns
which includes district issues what was
the origin
of proposing a regulation like this we
believe that this
is someone in the district's attempt
to keep employees from
speaking up about important issues
troubling many ccsd staff
as well as free speech attorney ari
combs it's
a policy that you can barely read four
sentences without hitting something that
it gets wrong
he found the document and posted a
twitter thread calling it a really bad
policy drafting i think the thing that
struck me
is that it seemed to quote language that
sounded familiar from the supreme court
cases
but the way it did it made you really
wonder if the people actually
read the cases the education support
employees association released a
statement
it says in part the trustees should
withdraw this embarrassing and
unconstitutional proposal or they will
waste district dollars having a court do
it for them
the clark county education association
tells me the union has nothing to share
at this time kristen drummond 8 news now
the aclu says it is analyzing the
document still
and waiting to hear back from its own
free speech experts on a national level
coming up next on politics now reforming
metro police
and so officers are dealing with with
homeless people
people who are sleeping on bus stop
benches
and you're right social workers could
fill that void
up next changes the police union says it
will talk about at the next legislative
session
in november our i-team did a week-long
series on police reform and what has
changed here
in the last year some of that includes
hiring and firing practices and use of
force policies
now after that series our george knapp
interviewed former district attorney
and a current police union attorney doug
david roger i beg your pardon
we talked about what would happen in the
upcoming legislature
so much unrest over the summer so much
anger around the country
state legislatures city governments
we're looking at
a variety of police reform options the
nevada legislature
included you went to the legislature
to present some options from the ppa
what was the reception uh we got the
stiff arm from
from the nevada legislature you know a
year earlier
the nevada legislature passed a peace
officer's bill of rights
these are procedural rights that
officers have during internal
investigations um 12 months later
the nevada legislature wiped all of that
that out and you know we felt i felt
that it was a knee jerk reaction you
know um
they had they had six months before six
seven months before
the 2021 legislature there was time to
for hearings and uh discussion about the
changes
and they wiped it out in in a matter of
two days
and and i felt that that was unfair to
the officers
and very unfortunate just a reaction to
the political environment the pressure
you know what we found uh was that uh
this was a vocal minority that was
pushing
uh all of these changes and it was a
national
national discussion but you know i
i believe and there is some empirical
data that the people of clark county
uh believe in their police officers they
don't want to defund
the police officers and although
they may not agree with every um
every incident or every policy that the
sheriff enacts
they have a great deal of faith in in
their police department
and i i just thought that the
legislature
played to the vocal minority is there a
way forward where we can
de-escalate the involvement of officers
in certain situations
mentally ill maybe redirect some money
and that resolves a lot of these
concerns or
not well i i don't want to redirect the
sheriff's money because
he knows where where the money should be
spent
but you know we we have a homeless issue
in
in clark county uh officer when
there's a problem people call the police
because they don't know who else to call
and so officers are dealing with
homeless people
people who are sleeping on bus stop
benches
and you're right social workers
could fill that void are there any other
reforms that you
your members your officers and ppa would
would uh
support or have in mind
you know i i think that as an
organization uh
you know metro police officers are
always looking
at cutting edge uh policies and tactics
and
and training they love to train they
don't have enough time to to train
but they're always willing to improve uh
what they some are not inclined to be
is the pinata to be beat on by the
legislature
when you know we are we've gotten the
stamp of approval from the department of
justice
you can watch the entire interview and
our series on police reform over at
eight newsnow dot com just look for the
politics now page
and the state of metro banner you'll get
the information you want to look for
coming up on politics now who will be in
charge of the committees in carson city
on those reform bills and who will have
to make it go through
nevada republican congressman mark
ameday says he has expressed interest in
running for governor in 2022.
i don't think it's news to anybody but
they think that governor sissel act
in some ways has made himself vulnerable
for reelection
i'm sure he doesn't agree with that and
i'm not going to be disrespectful
but it's like so so there's a lot of
people kicking tires right now
and we're certainly going to kick our
share of them here in the near future
amadeu made those comments during the
metro chamber of commerce eggs and
issues breakfast this week
amadeus holds the congressional district
2 seat up in northern nevada right now
other republicans whose names whose
names have been mentioned for a
potential gubernatorial run one of them
former senator dean heller we are only a
few months away from the 2021
legislative session in carson city
this week assembly committee assignments
were announced so let's take a look at
them
and of course with democrats in control
they're going to chair all of the
committees up there
first we'll look at well the wallets the
money ways and means will once again be
chaired by maggie carlton
with daniel monroe moreno as the vice
chair
the revenue committee will be chaired by
leslie cohen and teresa benitez thompson
is the vice chair
with police reform on the agenda the
judiciary committee could have some of
the key
bills going through there and it'll be
headed once again by steve yeager
rochelle nguyen will serve as the vice
chair education
always a top subject in carson city and
that committee will be headed by shannon
bilbray axelrod
brittany miller is the vice chair
bilbray axelrod is new
to the education committee we'll have
the latest on the legislative session
moving forward have a good rest of your
[Music]
weekend